[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense que pour tout comprendre il
faut que on reparte en
juillet 2006 ou non plutôt peut-être
l'été 1970 c'est là je pense qu'une
petite graine a été semée j'étais né
quelques années plus tôt à Lausanne je
l'aimais d'une famille de deux enfants
et je vais aller voir mes grands-parents
tous les ans dans le sud de la France et
mon grand-père m'emmenait visiter une
des plus belles grottes de France la
veine d'Orgnac c'est là que j'ai fait
mes premiers pas sous terre c'est là que
ma passion pour l'aspelo a dû voir le
jour et cette passion ne s'est jamais
arrêté
mon grand-père disparaît mes incursions
sous terre aussi je continue de grandir
partager entre les disputes de mes
parents c'est là que je pense aussi que
ce refus de la justice cette volonté de
protéger et de sauver à dû voir le jour
et cela qu'est-ce qu'en soit le prix à
payer
ce prix je le paierai l'année de mes 17
ans en retrouvant mes affaires devant la
porte mon père me priant de continuer ma
vie un tout petit peu plus loin
je continue je continue mes études je
passe mes examens je passe vivre je pars
vivre en Californie travailler là-bas je
rentre en France je rencontre celle qui
va devenir la mère de mes deux enfants
Jean et Anouk
bref une vie heureuse normale partagée
entre une vie professionnelle
épanouissante
deux beaux enfants et une passion
dévorante pour la montagne l'aspect
l'eau et les secours en milieu difficile
je reviens je m'investis je passe des
diplômes je passe des stages et je
prends la tête du spelo secours français
à partir de là je dirige avec succès des
opérations de secours en France puis à
l'étranger je suis reconnu pour mes
compétences et pour mon expertise
je pense à partir de là que plus aucun
secours ne pourra m'échapper que aucun
score ne sera trop difficile à faire je
pense en fait que je suis devenu
quasiment indestructible
ma fille Anouk a 12 ans ça fait 10 ans
qu'elle me suit un peu partout en France
lors de mes pérégrinations spéléo
Pâques 2006 on se retrouve à
Bourg-Saint-Andéol un petit village du
sud de la France avec mon ami Michel 85
ans un des premiers plongeurs Spello qui
prend un malin plaisir ce jour-là initié
mais deux enfants à cette pratique qui
lui est très cher
ce jour-là je fais une promesse à Anouk
je lui dis que tant qu'elle se fera
confiance et tant qu'elle me fera
confiance rien de grave ne pourra lui
arriver
pourtant quelques temps après des
douleurs apparaissent de plus en plus
fortes au fil des semaines le mot cancer
apparaît au mois de juillet dans le
courrier d'un spécialiste on le prend
pour un fou
pourtant tous les autres examens qui
vont arriver vont tous aller dans le
même sens
le vendredi 13 Juillet 2006 nous nous
retrouvons tous les trois à Strasbourg à
nous que sa maman et moi devant un
médecin qui nous annonce l'impensable
cette grosse tumeur cette grosse masque
qu'elle a sur la hanche la taille d'un
pamplemousse est une tumeur
bénigne ou non il faudra 10 jours
d'hospitalisation pour que le verdict
tombe c'est un cancer un stade très
avancé et ses chances de survie sont
bien entamées je n'entends pas ce
verdict
il me faudra plusieurs jours pour
réaliser la situation et à partir de là
tous s'enchaîne très vite les
hospitalisations les chimio
l'acceptation de protocoles pour adultes
des protocoles expérimentaux pour
adultes ces kilos qui disparaissent un
corps qui s'affaiblit une opération très
lourde prévue pour le mois de décembre
6 mois d'impuissance 6 mois de doute six
mois à regarder ma fille passer
souffrir passer d'une adolescente
rayonnante à une espèce de quilleuse
adulte
six mois pour que je comprenne que la
Maddie est bien là et qu'elle est
surtout beaucoup plus forte que mes
promesses de super héros de papier
nous sommes le 9 décembre au matin on
passe embrasser notre fille une dernière
fois avant qu'elle parte pour cette
longue opération
dont l'issue est assez incertaine on lui
fait un petit baiser léger alors qu'on
aurait voulu la serrer très fort dans
nos bras un baiser pour lui dire de que
tout aille bien se passer qu'il fallait
pas qu'elle s'inquiète qu'on serait
courageux comme elle et puis je fuis
l'hôpital pour pas devenir fou je verrai
dans cette ville qui a plus aucun
intérêt pour moi je suis écorché en fait
j'en veux à la terre entière je m'assois
une terrasse je bois un café un mendiant
passe de table en table pour chercher un
peu de monnaie c'est lui qui fait les
frais de ma colère j'ai dit ça va tu es
debout tu as deux jambes tu as deux bras
remue toi fais quelque chose les gens on
se retourne me regardent je pars
précipitamment
et je m'aperçois qu'en fait ma colère
n'a servi à rien et qu'il faut se
résigner et qu'il va falloir attendre
cette attente durera 17 heures ça a été
interminable
à nous que et dans un service donc oui
matopédiatrique c'est un univers à part
où les parents deviennent les parents
universels de tous les enfants ou les
enfants ont quitté le monde de l'enfance
mais sont pas encore tout à fait arriver
dans celui des adultes sont des enfants
qui ont des mots bruts tranchants on
leur a confié leur destin c'est à eux
seuls qui appartient la décision
d'arrêter ou non le traitement
bref c'est un univers très particulier
et quand on veut en sortir il faut
franchir une porte enlever une blouse
des surbots une charlotte traverse
traverser un sas et ressortir vers le
monde normal et un soir dans ce sas je
découvre un homme assez par terre la
tête entre les mains en larmes c'est le
chef de service le médecin qui soigne
tous les enfants de ce service et en qui
j'ai fondé tous les espoirs de sauver ma
fille une fille appelle plus jeune que
nous que venait de lui annoncer qu'elle
avait décidé d'arrêter ce traitement et
il est impuissant et je me dis si lui il
ne peut pas sauver ma fille et moi non
plus qui va pouvoir le faire
on s'était on s'était je venais voir à
nous qui en fait tous les après-midi je
passais l'après-midi avec elle et selon
suivant son état de santé on passait
notre après-midi à jouer à regarder
films ou à se parler et c'est au mieux
d'un de ces moments de complicité qu'à
nous que me pose brutalement la question
que feras-tu quand je serai morte
et là j'avoue que on n'est jamais
préparé aucun parent n'est préparé à
répondre à ce genre de questions de la
part de son enfant
cela fait maintenant 4 ans que notre vie
entière tourne autour de celle d'Anouk
Haïti en décembre 2010 et frappé de
plafouets par un tremblement de terre
meurtrier alors cette nouvelle me
prendre cours qu'est-ce que je dois
faire est-ce que je dois dépoussiérer ma
cape de super-héros et repartir à l'aube
du monde où est-ce que je dois rester
auprès de ma fille à l'hôpital c'est à
nous qu'en fait qui va décider pour moi
en disant qu'elle serait très fière que
je parte tenter de sauver des personnes
s'il y a encore des personnes à sauver
Haïti en arrivant là-bas c'était
pourtant habitué à ce genre de situation
mais la situation est vraiment vraiment
une situation compliquée 240
000 morts des destructions massives des
répliques brutales tous les jours une
population en deuil en larmes et tout
cela au lendemain de Noël
le sauvetage la petite Elisabeth qu'on
sortira des des gravats un bébé de
quelques jours sera une immense source
de joie un immense rayon de soleil pour
toute l'équipe qui va être très vite
ternie en fait par le nombre de victimes
décédées c'était vraiment c'était
vraiment terrible et un de mes derniers
chantiers aura été d'aller tenter de
retrouver une famille de quatre
personnes prisonnière d'une maison deux
étages qui s'était entièrement effondrée
il a fallu glisser à travers les dalles
passer le pièce en pièce dans ce qui
restait de leur appartement le sapin de
Noël était écrasé dans le salon
et la famille était dans le couloir un
peu plus loin surprise en pleine nuit
sans avoir pu s'extraire de ce piège
et là la question que je me pose c'est
qu'avait-il fait tous pour mériter cela
et je constate qu'une fois de plus je
peux pas sauver tout le monde
et je me dis que la vie elle est
vraiment super cruelle et super injuste
mon retour en France a pas été facile il
a fallu que je me réhabitue je me
reprenne pied dans une existence dont
finalement je comprenais pas le sens
on est le matin au lendemain d'une
énième lourde opération pour à nous
qu'un elle ouvre les yeux doucement
c'est le matin de son anniversaire
on lui offre la carte que lui à peinte
sa mamie l'équipe médicale est là au
complet aussi il lui chante bon
anniversaire tout le monde est très ému
et là d'un coup arrive un jeune homme
souriant avec un vin ou pas décidé il
vient directement vers nous c'est
Olivier le kiné il s'adresse directement
à nous et lui dit bon allez à nous que
on va pas perdre de temps on va tout de
suite commencer à faire quelques
exercices mais d'abord je vérifié s'il
serait un peu de souffle et quelques
minutes après il se retourne vers elle
et lui dit un tiers de capacité
pulmonaire c'est pas mal c'est un bon
début mais il va falloir t'accrocher en
fait ce ton direct cette manière de dire
les choses sans ambiguïté tout seul en
fait pour à nous qui est pour nous à
constituer quelque chose de nouveau
je passe 7 jours du temps avec Anouk et
on était ennuyé parce qu'on n'osait pas
parler de l'avenir on avait peur on
avait beaucoup de doutes aussi et alors
on s'est inventé un stratagème on a
imaginé que la vie était un saucisson et
que chaque jour on pouvait manger qu'une
tranche de saucisson et qu'on en
connaissait ni la longueur ni la forme
cette technique nous a super aidé et
surtout elle coupait court à toutes les
hypothèses qu'on pouvait avoir
une autre chose qui nous a aussi
énormément aidé c'est de ne pas prendre
pour argent comptant l'espèce d'avenir
noir que nous dressait les tous les
sachant qu'on croisait à nous ne pourra
jamais plus marcher à nous pas faire de
sport à nous pourra pas conduire de
voiture et on avait décidé qu'on a le
tout réessayer tout recommencer et que
seulement en cas d'échec on savourait
que c'est impossible à partir de là moi
j'ai pu reprendre la main sur plein de
petites choses des choses très
importantes pour nous
veillez sur l'intimité d'une adolescente
coincée sur une coque coincée dans une
coque sur le dos refaire du badminton en
changeant les règles l'emmener à la
piscine et recommencer à faire des
courses mais en nageant qu'avec les bras
acheter un van aménagé pour pouvoir
aller un peu voyager en France et sortir
de l'hôpital
faire transformer un vélo pour pouvoir
refaire des promenades ressentir le vent
sur la figure l'odeur de la sueur le
plaisir de faire ensemble
mais même qu'en effet tout cela il nous
manquait quelque chose quelque chose
qu'on voulait vraiment refaire ensemble
dont on avait vraiment envie c'était de
retourner sous terre
personne n'en parlait personne ne
l'évoquait cela semblait totalement
irréalisable totalement incongru
totalement impossible
mais nous on en avait vraiment envie
donc on est parti on est parti dans une
mine de Sainte-Marie
on est monté avec une roue de
carrossable jusqu'à l'entrée qui elle
était vraiment exiguë étroite et dans
laquelle il fallait ramper pour rentrer
et ça a été franchement une après-midi
inoubliable faite dans le plus grand
secret personne n'était au courant qu'on
essaie là-bas
à nous qu'un à la seule force de ses
épaules et de ses bras à parcouru ses
galeries pendant plusieurs heures
entre couper de quelques pauses ou on
buvait un thé qui nous brûlait les
lèvres dans ces galeries qui étaient
froides et humides et puis je suis le
retour puis assorti qui fut comme une
espèce d'allégorie au retour à la vie à
l'obstination payante et surtout un
immense plaisir d'avoir fait ensemble ce
que tout le monde nous avait demandé de
gommer à tout jamais
bien sûr après cette sortie les
allers-retours entre 102 rééducation
hôpital ne sont pas arrêtés à nous
passons bac au centre de rééducation
elle le tient qu'une mention bien tout
le monde est très fier d'elle autour
d'elle elle rêve d'être commissaire de
police
du coup pour donner corps à son rêve
elle fait des études de droit elle fait
un stage à l'Institut Médical
elle s'entraîne pour réussir le parcours
police et malgré tous ses efforts le
verdict de l'administration tombe motif
squelette non conforme
le rêve d'Anouk s'arrête là
aujourd'hui elle a réussi brillamment
ses études elle fait un travail qu'elle
aime c'est une jeune femme épanouie elle
a un sourire et des yeux magnifiques
elle va bien
cette expérience moi m'a appris
plusieurs choses la première c'est
l'absurdité de certaines phrases que les
gens s'entêtent à vouloir vous répéter
du genre ce qui ne vous tue pas vous
rend plus fort une ineptie totale pour
moi on ne sort pas plus fort de ce genre
d'épreuve on en sort plus dur à certains
endroits mais tellement plus vulnérables
à d'autres
ma vie de sauveteur m'a appris d'autres
choses tant qu'une personne
n'est pas retrouvée tant qu'une personne
n'est pas retrouvée vivante on ne peut
pas dire qu'elle est décédée une notion
aussi tant qu'il reste un souffle de vie
tous les espoirs sont permis
alors ma vie n'a pas été un long fleuve
tranquille après ça j'ai traversé
d'autres épreuves très difficiles et
très douloureuses tant sur le plan
personnel que sur le plan professionnel
mais
mon envie d'aller sauver les gens au
bout du monde n'a pas diminué mais j'ai
posé ma cape de super-héros aujourd'hui
je sais trois choses
premièrement il faut donner le maximum
de soi et savoir aller au bout des
choses deuxièmement
il est important
le soir de s'endormir sans regret et
d'être fier de sa journée et
troisièmement il est utile de savoir
attendre et voir en mangeant chaque jour
sa tranche de saucisson car le plus
important est de faire de son mieux
[Applaudissements]